Навесні спалахи громадського протесту охопили багато білоруських міст.
Причиною став Сергій Тихановський.
За короткий час йому вдалося стати найбільш впізнаваним критиком Лукашенка.
На думку оглядачів, білоруський президент вважає блогера небезпекою для свого режиму.
Я - Сергій Тихановський. Підприємець, блогер,
який у минулому році висловив свій протест і почав щось робити,
хоча довкола не було жодного однодумця.
І тепер, коли я приїжджаю у якісь міста в Білорусі,
виходять десятки, а тепер будуть, мабуть і сотні виходити людей,
які мислять так само, як і я. Хочуть змін.
Тихановський - бізнесмен. Йому належить студія "Компас",
яка працює у сфері відеозйомок.
У березні 2019-го Тихановський започаткував канал у Ютьюбі,
на якому він розповідає про життя в республіці,
і з тих пір це його основне заняття.
У Білорусі немає чесних незалежних судів. Це треба змінювати.
У Білорусі немає змінюваності влади. Фальсифікуються вибори.
У нас немає місцевого самоврядування.
Тихановський збирався балотуватися у президенти,
але його затримали й посадили під адміністративний арешт.
За цей час його канал "Країна життя" став дуже популярним.
Поки Тихановський перебував під арештом,
ЦВК позбавила його можливості брати участь у виборах.
Замість нього на посаду президента тепер балотуватиметься
його дружина Світлана Тихановська.
20 травня блогера звільнили з-під арешту.
Після звільнення Тихановський дав інтерв'ю DW,
в якому розповів, чому критикує Лукашенка і як буде допомагати виборчій кампанії дружини.
Це інтерв'ю переглянули на каналі Deutsche Welle більше півмільйона разів.
У нас всі гілки влади захоплені. Виконавча, законодавча, судова - все в руках диктатора.
Як можна перемогти диктатора? Практично неможливо.
Але якщо всі білоруси не боятимуться, висловлять свій протест,
частина з них стане спостерігачами на виборах,
якщо інша частина бойкотуватиме вибори,
і тоді дільничним виборчим комісіям нічого іншого не залишиться,
як визнати вибори такими, що не відбулися.
29 травня Сергія Тихановського знову затримали,
коли він проводив пікет зі збору підписів на користь
участі у виборчій кампанії його дружини Світлани.
Після затримання слідчі повідомили про порушення карної справи
за насильство стосовно міліції.
Дружина й потенційна суперниця Лукашенка звернулася із вимогою звільнити чоловіка.
Я відповідально заявляю, що пікет мав законний і мирний характер.
У зв'язку з цим я вимагаю негайно звільнити керівника моєї ініціативної групи.
У нас є підстави стверджувати про політичні мотиви переслідування Тихановського.
Ну а його самого ми визнаємо політичним в'язнем
і вимагаємо його негайного звільнення.
Оскільки сам Тихановський не скоїв жодних дій протиправних,
насильницьких, а реалізовував свої гарантовані міжнародними нормами свободи.
У родини блогера провели серію обшуків.
На дачі заарештованого знайшли буцімто майже мільйон доларів.
Експерти впевнені, що з наближенням дати виборів
тиск на блогера та його дружину лише посилиться.
Зараз фокус роботи влади - це не покарати його,
а створити йому репутацію злочинця, маргінала,
який незрозуміло де знаходить ці гроші, у якого
в команді багато людей із кримінальним минулим.
Його дискредитують насамперед в очах людей.
Для оглядачів очевидна схожість Тихановського з Навальним у Росії.
Якщо проводити паралелі, ким Ви себе відчуваєте:
білоруським Навальним, білоруським Зеленським? Кимось ще і чому?
Білоруським Тихановським.
Я не знаю, я дивився кілька роликів з Олексієм Навальним.
Я навіть зустрів його якось на вулиці.
Зеленський... У мене складні відчуття.
Я спочатку був радий, що нарешті в Україні такі позитивні зміни.
Зараз я бачу, що практично нічого не змінюється.
Є зміни, але настільки повільні та маленькі...
І великі сумніви в мене, що він самостійний.
Я не володію інформацією щодо України. Це моя суб'єктивна думка.
Олександр Лукашенко керує Білоруссю з 1994 року.
Це найдовший термін перебування на посаді
серед усіх європейських голів держав, за винятком монархів.
Тепер у білоруського президента нарешті з'явився справжній опонент,
який не боїться критикувати Лукашенка публічно і до якого дослухаються люди.
Це некомпетентна людина.
Виключно тримається за владу, не може від неї відірватися,
тому що розуміє, що якщо він піде, рано чи пізно
буде відповідати за злочини, які він скоїв.
Злочини перед білоруським народом. Їх величезна кількість!
Дата виборів президента Білорусі - 9 серпня цього року.
І хоча режим Лукашенка позбавив Тихановського права балотуватися,
блогер і його команда хочуть в інший спосіб вплинути на результати виборів.
Вони закликають білорусів масово бойкотувати голосування.
За словами Тихановського, саме з цією метою
реєструвалася кандидатом у президенти Світлана Тихановська:
мати можливість спілкуватися з громадянами і пояснювати доцільність бойкоту.